enfin rencontre avec plume une chienne
qui porte plutôt bien son nom
puisqu'elle est férue de littérature
tous les mercredis un vendredi un samedi
par mois elle accompagne sa référente
humaine dans les allées de la
bibliothèque Abbé Grégoire à Blois sa
mission rassurer les tout-petits et
aider ceux qui auraient des difficultés
d'apprentissage c'est ce qu'on appelle
la médiation animale plus d'explications
avec Audrey Champigny
[Musique]
depuis un an la mascotte de la
bibliothèque c'est elle une caniche
royale
âgée de trois ans qui prend très à cœur
son rôle d'assistante
mais il est très sage cet enfant tu
n'aurais pas dû le manger monsieur le
loup trop tard installez sur des tapis
les tout-petits sont captivés par les
histoires racontées par Christine mais
aussi et surtout par plume
quand il touchait la page pour tourner
la page j'ai trouvé ça sympa car oui
plume c'est même tourner les pages cela
fait partie de ses missions stimuler les
plus jeunes les apaiser et leur donner
confiance en eux une méthode appelée
lecture au chien qui a déjà fait ses
preuves au Canada ou enfin Landes nous
on vient régulièrement pour eux qui
puissent y avoir un déclic du coup pour
la lecture et pour que les enfants
aiment le plaisir de vivre parce que de
lire ce que c'est compliqué certains
enfants n'aiment pas forcément ouvrir un
livre et du coup là ça permet avec le
chien de pouvoir accéder à ça plus
facilement pour Solène les séances de
lecture avec plume lui permettent aussi
de vaincre une autre angoisse
affronter ma perte de chien parce que
c'est encore un petit peu peur des
chiens tes lunettes plus même beaucoup
dormir mais elle est toujours partante
pour jouir avec ses peluches faire
connaissance avec les enfants et de
promener au milieu de la bibliothèque on
parle beaucoup des bibliothèques
troisième lieu lieu de vie c'était
vraiment de donner envie de venir et de
créer un lien particulier effectivement
avec l'animal qui au-delà de l'animal
crée un lien aussi avec les autres
depuis qu'on a plus
on sent que les gens parlent plus entre
eux même les enfants ils communiquent
entre eux grâce à plume la bibliothèque
Grégoire de Blois a reçu il y a quelques
semaines le prix national de
l'innovation à Paris plumes a déjà tout
d'une star